CBS News chief Washington correspondent
and Face the Nation moderator John
Dickerson joins us from Washington John
good morning morning Gail let's continue
that conversation that chip just laid
out for us these executive orders have
they moved the needle significantly on
any of his campaign promises a little
bit but a lot of these executive orders
are orders to parts of his
administration to study things or look
into things or on steal for example to
to investigate so they don't actually
take action they just order his
administration to do reviews that would
then have to other things would have to
take place to actually take actions so
it's important to look at the actual
structure of these orders but they do
for a highly improvisational president
they do give direction to his
administration which is which is
something and obviously they are being
used in the same way President Obama
used them which is as public relations
moments to show that the president cares
about an issue but they're you know you
still have to go through Congress and
and so they don't that they're not
transformed transforming things as much
as perhaps the White House would like to
make how important is it for him do you
think John to have a legislative victory
sooner rather than later well he yes
certainly you would like one the
president came in saying he was going to
negotiate in ways that people had never
seen before and one of those jobs is
negotiating with the hill of course he's
trying to do it with things that are
very very complicated and complex so
it's not surprising that it would be
difficult to pass health care reform
regardless of the fact that the
president as a candidate said it would
be quite easy but I think there are lots
of other things happening with the
people he's appointed to things like the
Food and Drug Administration the Federal
Communications Commission certainly the
Justice Department that are changing the
way America will exist and and that
those appointments are changing and
rolling back Obama administration
regulations and rules in ways that are
quite transformative and that don't get
covered so much the president gave a
wide-ranging interview to Reuters in
which he expressed some really
interesting things he said he missed my
old life he thought it would be easier
the presidency he even said he missed
driving what does that tell us about him
well it tells us that he is a president
and like all previous presidents he
feels the constraints of the office Bill
Clinton
to say that the White House was the
nicest facility in the American penal
system which is and and the presidents
have always talked about the kind of
prison that the White House can be and
certainly President Obama felt that
acutely so it seems like President Trump
is feeling that as well John two
questions one nice haircut by the way
well thank you Charlie I I know you're
getting ready for the big interview
aren't you yes exactly brushing my teeth
flossing all those important things
Charlie well yeah do that how are you
going to prepare for this how does one
prepare for a big interview when this
president is doing other interviews and
you want it to be special well I I say
what would Charlie Nora and Gail do and
then I meditate on that for a while
Charlie not given you a lot to discuss
John that's for sure I'm saying that's
for sure yeah we just you know we just
cover the news every week and we write
down all the questions we don't get to
ask and then and then we go from there
and they put them in the book that's
right thank you John thanks y'all Sunday
on Face the Nation you can see the first
part of John's interview with President
Trump and we will feature more of the
conversation Monday on CBS this morning
when we broadcast from inside the White
House the